so hello once again so ah
in this session we are going to uh
discuss about how different or various
big data bioinformatics analysis methods
ah will uh will actually help you in
understand the bioinformatics of
infectious diseases and we will also in
addition to discussing uh the
application of different bioinformatics
analysis methods this program will also
show you uh several examples of these
analysis methods that are used in
pathogen diagnostics in evolutionary
studies of the virus and in the
discovery of antiviral drugs and
vaccines and the design of antiviral
vaccines as well as
to characterize emerging drug resistance
across
across the different packages so let's
go over this uh
briefly
go over the syllabus briefly so by the
end of the program you will be able to
explore relevant tools for
characterizing sequence variation and
sequence alignment at the whole genome
level you will be able to learn from
peer-reviewed publications and example
projects about how phylogenetic analysis
helped in understanding the emergence
and spread of pandemic like covet and
epidemic like ebola viruses so you will
also be able to master key analysis
methods and visualization tools
that are related to sequence variation
with functional properties of the
protein and
these tools will help you understand the
mutations that are critical for the
pathogenicity and are critical for the
functioning of the pathogens
you will also get an introduction to
study the host's response by analyzing
the transcriptomics data of the infected
host compared to the healthy host so we
can also understand how actively the
host is
responding to the pathogen or to the
infection in this case
so we will start again with the um
with an introduction to next gen
sequencing and we will discuss about
various ngs sequencing methods and we
will discuss about different data format
start used in the sequencing genome
whole genome sequencing data and we will
discuss about exploring
exploring the
tbio info server and exploring
visualization of the
reads that are mapped onto the whole
genome sequence in this case vital
sequence or pathogens sequence using a
visualization tool such as a j browser
and etc
then we will follow this up with uh
understanding uh follow this up with
getting an introduction to multiple
sequence alignment methods and
phylogenetic tree analysis to understand
the viral adaptations in the mutations
that are characterizing the different
pathogens so we will also work with an
example projects and examples of
deadly mutations in ebola and how that
translates into
different
virulence are different uh effects of
pathogenic effects of ebola virus so we
will also get to compare uh multiple
sequences at amino acid level at
nucleotide level and also compare
different methods for constructing
phytogenetic key analysis will visualize
the phytogenetic three and fellow
genetic tree results using specific
software
that is available for tree analysis and
also for
understanding multiple sequence
alignment
so in this uh hands-on session this will
be a combination this will be a
follow-up hands-on session to the
session that you studied before and
discussed before so where
you will be shown how to build a
pipeline so that you can perform
multiple sequence alignment of viral
genomes and a phylogenetic tree analysis
using different phylogenetic key methods
so you will also be given um
an introduction to different analysis
pipelines uh like selecting appropriate
genomic sequences and selecting uh
different pipeline
methods that is suited for either fast q
files are suited for faster files
so we will also uh analyze the output
discuss the pipeline results and analyze
how to perform the downstream analysis
of the pipeline outputs and what to do
if we have a faster file and possibly
file for input and we will also
understand which databases to use to uh
to gather in
together information regarding the viral
sequences and we will also see how to
interpret the phytogenetic tree analysis
that is uh that is the result of
different different phylogenetic three
methods and how to understand the
evolutionary relationships between the
genomes in terms of uh evolutionary time
in terms of mutation and in terms of uh
birth and death of different strains
that are uh
yeah that are
with the varying degree of pathogenicity
and then from there we will go to uh
understand how
viral transmission occurs
across species and we will take this or
we will understand with the help of
ebola virus and what are the
specific insights we
learned from studying the epidemic of
ebola which is as clearly as mentioned
as one of the first epidemic that is
studied or that is real time track using
next generation sequencing data and we
will also understand the origins of
these viral adaptations and we will also
extend this analysis to novel corona
virus genome sequence so that we can
compare
the
novel coronavirus
sars 2 viral sequence with the other
related viral sequences
and we will get a good introduction to
how the disease progresses once the
virus
infects the host so uh what happens and
what are the functional domains of
different
proteins for uh that for example spike
proteins and different proteins that are
uh
involved in ah involved in the
disease progression and involved in
helping the virus getting access into
the cellular
different cellular
cytosol and how this virus
uses or hijacks the hosts
cellular mechanisms to
enable its own progression and we will
also understand
understand how this
how the disease how the
pathogen
evades the immune response of the host
in this session
and then what follows is a hands-on
session of an example project and this
example project will compare
uh the sars2 whole genome sequence with
the other uh um with the other related
viral sequence of sars
mers and other um
to understand how
uh how in
how related sars to novel coronavirus
whole genome sequences with the other
viral sequences we will also take uh
such two sequence from different hosts
so that we can understand the zoonotic
origin of source two and how such two is
related to uh for example um
two different parts of such two how it
is uh related to uh different hosts like
from bad from pangolin etc
and then we will also understand the
understand how to
analyze the mutation
mutation types and how to analyze
different mutation types like synonymous
mutation missense mutation
non-synonymous mutation and how to
calculate the rate of this mutation and
how to map these mutation rates uh onto
the spike protein for example or onto
the protein so that we can get and
get a visualization or hands-on
visualization or exploring
exploring the protein structures
and
that is color coded or that is mapped on
for the mutation rate and that is
different position so we will use uh
ucsf camera
and
softwares like camera camera x and
primal for this specific visualization
and then we will also understand uh
understand what are the different low
frequency mutation and how will they
actually enable the virus to maintain
its virulence and what are the different
annotations uh on what are the different
locations on genome and proteome
genome and protein different protein
that is that contains these mutations
and how
it relates to the accumulation of
mutation only on the specific areas of
for example spike protein and other
related proteins so that the
virus adapts itself to maximize its
virulence and remain fit in the
evolutionary pressure
so
finally we will also understand the host
side or whose response to such
pathogenic
pathogenic
infection so we will get an uh we will
get an introduction to uh
transcriptomics data analysis we will
get an introduction to what is measured
from the post side and
how we can perform a comparative rna-seq
pipeline analysis so that we can
identify key responses from the host
site for the pathogenic interaction so
we can understand uh how uh different
for example healthy holes and infected
hosts differ in terms of their immune
response and what are the different
factors for considering vaccine design
when
after identifying a specific host
response and pathways
so
this
program will also culminate in helping
you to design a bioinformatics research
and bioinformatics research project
you will be uh you'll be able to uh
choose your topic for for your project
and then again you will be
explained where to extract data for for
example related to infectious diseases
and related to
specific viral repositories and then
we will also get a lot of hands-on
training on how to perform these
analysis over the course of program that
you can apply onto your own tracking so
i i want to highlight
three related publications that is uh
that is published in 2022 and
with the available number of public with
the available number of
data that is deposited in the public
repositories uh for coding this program
and these analysis methods will enable
you to learn or when it will enable you
to understand uh how these studies are
performed and then you can
generate your own research question in
the very relevant pandemic error and
which still
helps you to understand different
aspects of sars scope to infection and
and how big data bioinformatics is
generally
helping us tracking this pandemic and
also preparing us for any future attacks
in the uh in the upcoming years so
we all know how uh uh
source code to data the rich data has
enabled understanding the
different um
variants of concern or variance of
interest what are the different
relationship between these variants and
how ah in real time how these phylogeny
dynamics is being tracked and how these
um
how these different variants are related
to each other and we also can get an
introduction to how the
virus actually enables itself for how
this virus actually has an intra host
variation uh level that is not being
explored in detail uh previously so to
get a scale of to get an understanding
of uh
on the scale of genomes uh that is being
tracked with the with the um
with the kovid19 response so within a
month of uh uh within a month of uh
infection uh we we got almost an uh an
average of 1300 genomes were being
submitted to
ncbi and being submitted to desired
database uh per day regularly and within
the six months of start of the pandemic
uh
gizzard had almost like 110 000
full-length scope to genome sequences so
by the end of december by the end of
2021 two years into the pandemic we had
67 000 genomes that were deposited to
the public viral genome repositories per
day daily so currently the repositories
like uh giza genbank ncbi virus and cog
uk everything all of these combined to
contain over 6 million star spoke to
genomes
in its entirety so we can see where
the palo genetic studies and different
surveillance studies are performed all
over the world and
and irrespective of different uh
different continents all the continents
contribute to uh tracking this viral
pandemic in real time and that that is
possible
mainly through the analysis of big data
analysis of the next generation
sequencing data and that has enabled us
to understand and also keep uh exploring
the data for future patterns and for
further patterns that is uh that is
so rich in in its variety and
and uh throwing as lot of surprises so
one of that is uh one of the surprise or
one of that uh
key uh discovery is the
in-host diversity of this virus or its
ability to
adapt itself to inhost
within the hosts
based on the host's response so this
what this means this means that
the viral
in the viral sequences that that for
example that causes severe symptoms or
whose virulence has
has an increased rate of virulence
has a different variation compared to
the
virus whose virulence has mild symptoms
so
understanding this in-house diversity
will pave way for us to arrest this
development or this increase in the
virulence factor of this virus and
thereby even if the virus spreads from
the host to um to the inter-host or
different
to the to the different individual we
can actually make sure that not the most
virulent virus is going to
spread and going to cause
infection for the other diseases so we
also get
get an overview in
in what is being currently studied and
what has been clinically valued in in
the current pandemic scenario for
example we value a lot on
genomics and transcriptomic data only
about the scope and from the viruses
point of view mostly the genomics data
is what has been considered
really informative but we have a whole
plethora of our mixed data from the host
and also from the
viral
from the pathogens responses which can
be
integrated into a uh big multi-omic
studies and that aspect of this
infectious disease
scenario
pandemic scenario has not been explored
in detail so far so there are still lot
of opportunities there to develop
methods that will effectively integrate
for example the host response to the
pathogens and also the virulence levels
of the pathogens to the
host response to study how these two ah
how these two uh
partner in it in the
effective
transmission of the virus so ah
we have uh we have not even touched
about how uh how or what are the
long-term effects of for example kovit
infection so uh into the third year of
the pandemic and
we we have uh still a lot of data
that can be studied for example uh for
the symptoms that prevail uh what
happens after one year or two years of
uh
years of the infection already there are
studies that
that
that try to characterize the fatigue
level that try to characterize that um
they try to characterize the
loss of smell and taste level of the
host individual after several weeks and
several months of
kovic infection so this
pandemic and also this infection
has actually thrown up a lot of
opportunities which are being currently
explored at the different degree and
under the increased rate and this
program will enable you to first
understand and dissect all of these
analysis methods and then develop
an analysis method for your own for a
different dataset so that we can
understand the biology of these
infectious diseases or you can
understand apply these methods to
to another disease of your interest and
and
gain lot of
experience in the bioinformatics
analysis of infiltration so with that i